has been really fun I love talking to
you you know that yeah I I
um and I you and I don't even know that
I can't even tell you what we talked
about but it's just uh effortless with
you
and um until like the past minute or so
I just feel like I don't know I've got
nothing
well that's terrible you're never
supposed to you just you just Telegraph
that to the audience yeah never do that
never let the audience think they're
getting anything less than a spectacular
show it's been amazing Conan I think the
last minute's been the best part
probably yeah just laughs huh
well we can add those later
is this for later
than anything else
uh well listen I do consider you a good
friend and I why aren't you looking at
me in the eye when you say that because
I don't really
because
I do consider you look at this I'm
looking right in the eye and you know
what you who has who else have this
problem with Kevin Neal and we don't
look each other in the eye but you're at
the same height and everything I know
that's the tragedy of it all our
eyeballs are at the exact same height
that is my favorite okay that hurt oh
second pair of tired well it's fine
you're not really a stand
um I guess no oh my God it's just no I
don't know what I am I guess oh God
helps you before
I know but this is fun you do do stand
over you have done something you don't
stand up tour please please please no no
I am not a true stand-up I know that I
don't I think I'm you're more you know
what I am I'm a man that just lives by
his wits uh
uh whatever you project onto me I become
that
um that would be good a good like not
naked and afraid but like just drop
Conan somewhere and he has to just find
his way yeah that was called the 60s 70s
and 80s
yeah
go too well but that's not the point the
point is that we are good friends and
I'm looking you right now yeah we're
definitely friends and uh your eyes look
fantastic I see no sign of glaucoma oh
really yeah I think your cones and rods
are looking spectacular and
um I think your hearing is fun oh can I
ask you a question about sight sure I'm
the guy to ask
um this is what I do like I've just been
going when I get a email from the
eyeglass store that I get my glasses
from and then there's a doctor there and
they're like time to get a checkup like
I don't go to a
I don't know if he's an optometrist he
like has a glasses store well does he
make you look through a device yes and
uh does he compare which e is sharper
which a is sharper better better worse
worse better worse then he's then he's
fitting you for he's giving you a
prescription knowing all of it is he
checking your peripheral vision is he
you know dilating your pupils I think so
okay I check sona's peripheral vision
every day by trying to attack her oh
that's nice and you know what you're
still really good I am I that's because
I get my peripheral vision checked by an
actual optometrist
I used to go on the road with my friend
Mark Cohen the other Coco and he would
drive and I would sit there and I would
fall asleep and then when I'd wake up he
would notice that I was wake up waking
up I don't know if you say this on the
how to say this but he would close his
like right eye and act like he was
sleeping you know that's great and I'd
wake up and I'd be like more
a lot of good ones and then he had a
good one like if you have a cold like
ghost like sniff this is visual sort of
but like sniffle like you have a cold
act like it holds him towards you it's
just so quick like how do you do that
that fast that's like TIG when if you go
to give her a high five which for some
reason I do fairly regularly she goes
like go to give me a high five
question
I would never try to give TIG a high
five I know I go why does this happen so
much that I give try to give her a high
five I don't know no one gives off don't
give me a high five energy like take
Notaro you know it's true just I mean
the best but she's just yeah don't even
don't you want to now knowing what
she'll probably I'm going to yeah
um they're kids their twins are obsessed
with Rory which makes me so happy like
we'll get texts from them saying like
one of the kids was like oh this is
Rory's favorite team you know like it's
just there's love it so much but Rory is
so good with them like they came over
one day and he just like he just knew
what they want they're like six-year-old
twin boys and they're so cool and
they're such good kids but like you know
they're bouncing around and Rory works
and hey you guys want to drill holes in
some wood yeah
I would be in for that too that just
sounds fun it does sound cool man her
kids I'm I'm really good with kids I can
make kids laugh I cannot crack her twins
can't get them they're Tiny still you
have twins I have twin boys they're
almost a year and a half and they're you
know they'll they'll get there they'll
get there where they appreciate you I've
used props I know you've used a lot of
things physical humor since you died I
bought all of Gallagher's props and I
tried the next day I snatched them up
yeah and um these are watermelons from
the 1990s and uh I could not get them I
couldn't get them you'll get them you
will you know little babies love they
love the sound of appalled old Rich
ladies that's one thing
it always makes them laugh the little
babies when I I have noticed young kids
love it when an adult consistently makes
a mistake and they they get to be in the
power position
so when I go over to my head writer
Matt's house his kids
um I always do the same thing I'll be
like do you have a bathroom here I can
use and he'll be like and then I'll cut
Matt off before he can say anything and
be like trust me forget it I know where
the bathroom is and I intentionally walk
into the closet with great bravado and
the kids go now oh my God now he's crazy
he's crazy and then I come out and I say
trust me and now I know where the
bathroom is and then I walk into the
swimming pool or I do and they just love
grown up
is consistently wrong yeah I get that
which is not funny as you get older as
you get older you it makes you afraid
they love it also they like when you're
mad but like they can sense it's a joke
you know like they'll go I'm taking a
nap don't wake me up yeah yeah and then
I do this
yeah which is my favorite and then they
always will like poke me and I'll go oh
yeah they love it for some reason but
then when it turns to real anger it
frightens them yeah then I start
slamming
smashing and then you're not
kidding me up remember when there was an
entire kill you oh my God that's how
that's I always start playing that game
that you're describing but then I really
do get upset and then I I threatened to
to kill them how old are you four you're
a piece of
do you have any idea how burnt sleep is
to me
I'm gonna get you in the night tonight I
know how to get into your room
oh
and then it goes it turns sour
we're gonna wrap this up now Sarah
Silverman God bless you
and uh thank you so much for being here
always a joy I love you I love you too
and look I'm looking oh my God I was
kidding no I do love you I'm kidding I
really do love you